[Musica]
a elisabetta
io tutto la stanza delle meraviglie come
l'immaginiamo è sicuramente diverso da
quello che nella realtà troviamo la
stanza delle meraviglie può essere
grigia e anonima come è stato il mio
caso che vi racconterò ma può essere
anche magica innovativa intimorente può
assumere varie forme possiamo sapere
benissimo quale fin dall'inizio possiamo
scoprire qual è stata minuto dopo
esserne usciti possiamo essere sorpresi
possiamo essere spaventati dalla nostra
stanza delle meraviglie ma comunque
tutti dovremmo averne una tutti nessuno
escluso
la storia che vi racconterò nella storia
della mia stanza delle meraviglie e non
è quella che vedete le mie spalle e più
questa qui una stanza come dicevano i
presentatori grigia e anonima una stanza
come si trova in un ufficio qualunque in
una città qualunque pareti grigie mobili
vecchi quindi nulla di ispirante nulla
di particolarmente bello però però è il
mio caso
nonostante questa apparenza è stata
davvero magica e vi racconterò il perché
molti anni fa e devo dire qualche chilo
fa e avevo qualche capello in più
evidentemente stiamo parlando di una
ventina d'anni fa avevo i miei primi
passi nelle aziende
avevo la possibilità di fare un
colloquio di feedback con quello che era
allora il mio capo arrivo con un po di
arroganza tipica dell'età
ero convinto che tutto sarebbe andato
per il meglio e tutto sarebbe stato rose
e fiori che avrei ricevuto
congratulazioni complimenti e pacche
sulle spalle
nulla di tutto ciò
in realtà ho ricevuto un feedback molto
negativo doccia fredda
mi fermo non capisco io mi sento molto
bravo nel mio mestiere
forse il più bravo e allora perché il
mio capo non la vedeva come me devo dire
che mi ricordo tutto di quella stanza
l'atmosfera i mobili i colori gli odori
la vista la luce qualsiasi cosa mi
ricordo come se fosse adesso come se non
fosse successo vent'anni fa il mio capo
però se una cosa chiudendo quella
conversazione sepino tu sei una persona
di grande talento
io credo che se tu uscendo da questa
stanza mette in testa di trovare un
nuovo lavoro troverà un nuovo lavoro più
bello forse anche più retribuito ma
faresti la cosa sbagliata perché se
quello che ti ho detto non lo risolvi
ora qui non lo risolverà in mai più nel
corso della tua carriera
sono convinto che è una grande
opportunità
sono convinto che farai la scelta giusta
e devo dire che mi ha lanciato un guanto
di sfida che era impossibile non
raccogliere infatti il mio orgoglio la
raccolto e da lì inizia il mio percorso
all'interno delle aziende
un percorso che mi ha portato a vivere
da dentro le organizzazioni a lavorare
grandi aziende a vederle là dentro a
cercare di capire come potevano evolvere
le stesse aziende manager e le persone
che le abitano
e da questo punto di vista sicuramente è
stato un continuo apprendimento
un viaggio di scoperta continua
vi racconto un po che cosa ho visto che
cosa penso possa arrivare le aziende
stanno cambiando stanno cambiando in
maniera profonda il primo punto sono
passate dai bisogni ai desideri degli
anni 70 80 anche negli anni 90 le
aziende rispondevano a dei bisogni caro
consumatore ha un bisogno
ecco la soluzione ecco il prodotto oggi
in realtà le aziende comunica un
desiderio
faccio alcuni esempi c'è una cosa che
trovo geniale un'azienda di detersivi ha
raccontato che sporcarsi è bello e lo
trovo veramente geniale facendo vedere
dei bambini che giocano in una
pozzanghera non comunica il prodotto
comunica un desiderio desiderio di
sporcarsi nelle pozzanghere
ci sono tantissimi altri esempi che
possiamo fare il fast food cosa comunica
hamburger e patatine no comunicherò la
spensieratezza di una serata in famiglia
sorridente che si può veramente provare
piacere a vivere ma le stesse aziende
che fanno pneumatici in realtà
comunicano il concetto della sicurezza
quindi non c'è più un bisogno ma c'è un
desiderio
i messaggi sono cambiati prima la
pubblicità comparativa oggi che cos'è il
consumatore che diventa ambasciatore del
prodotto tre esempi molto semplici le
banche non comunicano più i tassi dei
mutui comunicano una nuova coppia che
entra per la prima volta in casa le
aziende di assicurazioni non comunicano
anche qui le possibili polizze ma
comunicano il senso di protezione
magari anche degli animali nuovi
compagni delle nostre famiglie e non so
se vi ricordate qualche anno fa
un'azienda di pasta molto famosa verità
comunicava il concetto di pasta spedendo
il famoso pacco al figlio che studiava
all'estero bisogno desiderio
il messaggio diventa storia messaggio
diventa evidentemente più avvolgente più
importante più rilevante ma le
organizzazioni cambiano anche dal loro
interno non solo come comunicano oggi le
organizzazioni sono sempre più degli
organismi viventi è difficile pensare
che un organigramma mansionario possano
raccontare la ricchezza delle relazioni
che c'è all'interno delle organizzazioni
non è possibile
le organizzazioni sono esseri viventi e
si basano sulle loro fantasie sulle loro
amicizia sulle loro simpatie sulle
connessioni sulle antipatie sono esseri
che si modificano un po come le cellule
del corpo umano ma anche manager non
possono in questo contesto non cambiare
evidentemente il manager vecchio stile è
il manager di colui che controlla tutto
che comanda che dà le indicazioni che a
tutte le risposte
il manager oggi invece dovrebbe essere
sempre di più un attivatore di energie
un attivatore di passioni all'interno
delle proprie organizzazioni
il qualcuno che è in grado di guidare
trasportare ispirare le persone che
lavorano con lui è evidente che da
questo punto di vista la parte che
abbiamo visto in molti film degli anni
70 80 in cui il manager solo al comando
alla plancia aveva tutte le risposte si
relazionava con fare duro non può essere
efficace in un contesto del genere deve
essere sempre più umano deve portare
sempre più il lato umano all'interno
della propria organizzazione
si calcola che i manager a il top
management conosce dal 5 al 10 per cento
dei problemi della propria azienda
perché perché è distante da dove i
problemi si originano e allora manager
di questo tipo può avere tutte le
risposte
probabilmente no deve fare le giuste
domande
e fare il giusta domanda all'interno
dell'organizzazione andando ad
accorciare le distanze e andando a
toccare le persone che possono avere le
risposte e che possono aiutare l'azienda
devolvere evidentemente un manager di
questo tipo è molto più umano molto più
vicino smette di recitare una parte e
deve portare il proprio autentico se
stesso all'interno dell'organizzazione
ma cambiano anche le persone e forse il
cambiamento più grande è proprio lì si
misura ancora forse un po troppo
l'orario di lavoro ma all'orario di
lavoro a una bellissima convenzione si
immagina che quando uno è in azienda
seduta la propria scrivania stia
producendo beh è un falso storico perché
in realtà la passione la voglia che ci
mettono dentro è molto variabile ce la
possono mettere dal divano di casa dal
salotto di un cliente o dal prodotto
alla propria scrivania in ufficio
quindi da questo punto di vista sarebbe
molto più sensato misurare la output
cosa producono le persone
indipendentemente da dove lo producono
le aziende negli anni passati
nascevano su un concetto quella della
crescita infinita quello del fatto che
tutte le persone all'interno
dell'organizzazione all'interno
dell'azienda potessero crescere
all'infinito
beh ci sono stati anni in cui ciò è
stato possibile in quelle organizzazioni
dicevano alle persone dove sarebbero
state a 12 24 e 36 mesi
oggi evidentemente non è più possibile
quindi dal percorso predefinito si è
passato alla costruzione individuale del
proprio percorso di sviluppo all'interno
delle organizzazioni l'ufficio
evidentemente non è più fico
tradizionale il concetto del 9 17 seduto
davanti alla scrivania
forse lascia il campo a un concetto di
ufficio diffuso dove io posso lavorare
anche probabilmente dal salotto di casa
possono essere altrettanto efficace
altrettanto efficiente grandi importanti
trasformazioni che stanno avvenendo già
oggi si parla di futuro del lavoro ma in
realtà
futuro del lavoro è già nostro presente
e allora come facciamo a interpretare
quello che arriverà non abbiamo la sfera
di cristallo
io ho men che meno nessuno l'ha e
diffidate da chi crede di averla però
qualcosa la possiamo dire possiamo
pensare che la tecnologia l'intelligenza
artificiale le macchine i computer
giocheranno un ruolo importante sì ma un
ruolo non fondamentale nella stanza
delle meraviglie il pc per il jazz
artificiale le macchine non entreranno
perché le macchine non saranno mai in
grado di essere empatiche di essere
creative di essere innovative queste
sono caratteristiche tipicamente umane e
ritornando alla mia camera delle
meraviglie un computer un robot non
avrebbe mai potuto tirar fuori quello
che ha tirato fuori da me in quel
determinato momento il mio capo di
allora a cui sono evidentemente
eternamente grato quindi il futuro del
lavoro sarà evidentemente digitale ma
sarà soprattutto molto umano perché la
stanza delle meraviglie è decisamente
umana
e allora chiudo dicendo che da un paio
di consigli primo ritorno al punto di
inizio
tutti dovremmo avere la nostra stanza
delle meraviglie
se non l'avete trovatela perché è
decisamente importante
il secondo consiglio che do che anche
l'idea di chiusura è che la stanza delle
meraviglie non deve essere giudicata
alla luce degli arredi alla luce degli
oggetti di design
alla luce di quanto appare bella ma deve
essere giudicata per quello che ci
ispira ad agire
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]